parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
équilibre à votre magazine sur
l'environnement ce mois ci nous abordons
le thème du tri des déchets dans une
déchetterie de versailles grand parc
nous vous informerons sur la façon de
trier au mieux ses déchets et sur le
rôle que peut jouer ce cri au sommaire
également découverte de la permaculture
avec l'association sky en transition qui
proposait un atelier à magny les hameaux
une voiture de course solaire démarré sa
saison par une séance d'essai sur le
circuit de satory découverte des hall le
prototype de l'écurie mais tout de suite
nous partons à versailles sur le site
des matelots derrière nous ou le montage
des prototype d'habitat solaire du solar
decathlon a débuté reportage le solar
decathlon 2014 c'est parti depuis le 16
juin les 20 équipes en compétition ont
en effet débuté le montage de leur
prototype d'habitat solaire à pailles
réel ne disposant que de 11 jours pour
bâtir leur construction
l'heure est déjà à l'urgence sur le site
des matelots à versailles le chantier on
a commencé lundi dernier c'est déjà
cinquième jour
10 on est sur un système de 3,8 trois
équipages on dort pas beaucoup il y en a
qui dorment même plus voilà forcément
c'est un projet ambitieux dont il ya pas
mal de choses à faire la dernière à la
dernière minute avant le début des
travaux un partenariat avec erdf a été
signé pour équiper le site et ainsi
permettre aux équipes en compétition de
travailler dans les meilleures
conditions
des conditions qui respectent l'esprit
environnementale du solar pour cette
opération on a créé un réseau
intelligent dédié spécifiquement à cette
opération
nous avons installé un transformateur au
moyenne tension basse tension de
dernière génération et nous allons
mettre des compteurs communicants linky
que nous allons déployer très
prochainement sur l'ensemble du
territoire national à partir de fin 2015
des bornes de véhicules électriques ont
aussi été installés des tests grandeur
nature pour la société avant une
généralisation auprès du grand public
erdf sera à l'issue de l'événement
capable de mesurer l'impact d'un
écoquartier sur son réseau de
distribution
ce genre d'écoquartier d'initiative sur
l'échelle de 23 villes 1 et 2
une dizaine de bornes pour les véhicules
électriques va nous permettre de
modéliser les impacts sur ce réseau
électrique et ainsi demain quand ils
vont se développer en masse prévoir les
matériels innovants et notre façon de
conduire les réseaux pour je dirais
assumer cette présence de d'écoquartier
produisant de l'énergie
inauguration officielle du solar
decathlon le vendredi 27 juin les
nettoyages de printemps se sont succédé
dans les communes yvelinoise alors
quelle est la meilleure façon de trier
ses déchets et surtout quel rôle peut
jouer ce tri entretien bonjour un
taillis robe
johan djourou olivier nous sommes ici
sur la déchetterie de intercommunal de
bois d'arcy l'occasion pour nous de
faire un point sur la communauté
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
et les services que vous proposez
alors déjà l'état des lieux combien de
traiter de déchets traités vous et pour
combien de personnes ont alors faut
savoir que versailles grand parc et d'un
regroupement de 18 communes depuis
janvier 2014 ce qui représente à peu
près 250 mille habitants
nous avons collecté en 2013 plus de
soixante neuf mille tonnes de déchets
donc on propose différents services aux
habitants comme la collecte en porte à
porte pour les ordures ménagères le
verre des déchets recyclables et déchets
végétaux la collecte en point d'apport
volontaire pour aussi les déchets
recyclables les ordures ménagères et le
verre et les textiles et nous proposons
aussi des points de collecte le samedi
matin pour tout ce qui est déchets
électriques et électroniques déchets
toxiques et nous avons aussi depuis 2010
mis en place le compostage individuel
chez les habitants nous sommes ici sur
une déchetterie la déchetterie
intercommunale de bois d'arcy
pourquoi acheminer ces déchets verts une
déchetterie alors la déchetterie bois
d'arcy a été construite en mars 2012
nous avons proposé ce service aux
habitants afin de
de mieux valoriser les déchets notamment
des encombrants qui sont qui sont propre
femme déposée en porte à porte
là ça permet vraiment de valoriser les
déchets en fonction de leur catégorie
donc il ya différents types de ben la
ferraille les déchets végétaux le bois
les gravats et aussi ça permet de donner
à l'habitant un service supplémentaire
avec une plage horaire d'ouverture assez
importante parce qu'elle est ouverte du
lundi au dimanche
donc l'habitant peuvent venir déposer
ses déchets qu à n'importe quel moment
il n'est pas obligé d'attendre les
collectes enfin les jours de collecte en
porte à porte et puis aussi ça permet de
proposer l'habitante de déposer des
déchets qui ne sont pas pris en porte à
porte comme les gravats où les collectes
pas en porte à porte les déchets
toxiques parce que comme on dit sont
toxiques donc vaut mieux pas les déposer
en porte à porte et les déchets
électriques et électroniques vous
parlais tout à l'heure de valorisation
des déchets est ce que ces objets jetés
peuvent avoir une deuxième vie
alors ils ont une deuxième vie dans la
valorisation matière ce qu'on appelle
valorisation matière par exemple c'est
le déchets électriques et électroniques
donc on va prendre le sèche cheveux par
exemple il est fait de plastique
ce plastique là il est là on se déchaîna
il est des mots clés il récupère le
plastique et ce plastique permet par
exemple de 2
de faire des pare chocs de voitures ou
des objets en plastique donc c'est
important de sensibiliser les gens oui à
cette deuxième vie des déchets donc
cette valorisation
oui tout à fait nous nous avons
différentes actions pour pour
sensibiliser les habitants sur le tri
des déchets depuis deux ans nous nous
mettons en oeuvre un agenda qui est des
qui est donné à l'ensemble des écoliers
de versailles grand parc ou dedans vous
pourrez voir qu'il y à pleins d'astuces
pour trier les déchets des informations
sur l'eau aussi des informations sur ce
que deviennent les déchets nous
sensibilisons aussi les habitants sur le
compostage individuel en leur en les
formant sur le compostage
nous avons aussi un numéro vert qui
permet aux habitants de nous appeler du
lundi au vendredi pour nous poser des
questions et nous nous sommes là pour
leur répondre et donc essayer de changer
les habitudes des gens voilà essayer de
changer les habitudes des gens notamment
sur sur l'or que leur consommation sur
le notamment aux autres de réfléchir que
lorsqu ils jettent leurs déchets est ce
qu'il est vraiment cas c est ce qu ils
peuvent le réparer ou le donner à une
association par exemple comme les
vêtements
il ya des personnes qui jettent des
vêtements ils peuvent contacter des
associations pour donner
ces objets aux associations si je vous
comprends bien les gens jettent alors
qu'il pourrait les réparer plutôt que
d'aller jouer là où même les revendre
merci beaucoup nasa les robes pour
toutes ces explications
merci beaucoup au revoir au revoir un
atelier découverte de la permaculture se
tenait à magny les hameaux initiation
avec une philosophie qui harmonise
activités humaines et écosystèmes claire
cambier pour les images harmoniser
l'activité humaine avec l'écosystème
tel est le principe de la permaculture
que l'association sky en transition
permettait de découvrir lors d'un
atelier ce mois ci à magny les hameaux
utilisez des poules pour réguler la
population d'insectes nuisibles à votre
potager se servir de leurs excréments
comme engrais pour enrichir vos sols les
techniques durables ne manquent pas en
permaculture
en fait nous permettre aux tueurs ont
peu à peu ça qui est ça à sa vie
quotidien de façon dans son jardin de sa
maison
chez soi santé un arbre fait un jardin
avec vous et concevoir la façon dont on
va récupérer des faits à la maison
d'abord initié via un cours théorique
les participants étaient ensuite amené
sur le terrain pour découvrir comment
appliquer la permaculture à l'échelle
d'une ville n'ont besoin en tant qu'être
humain son prochain départ à ses besoins
d'arbres à ses besoins donc on peut
parler de des besoins de tout le monde
et et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
que des besoins de tout le monde soit un
peu mieux soit soit bien venté en fait
on n'a pas envie de se poser à la façon
dont le monde tourne aujourd'hui on a
tout simplement envie
de mieux de mieux trouver sa place et de
jouer un rôle sur notre territoire au
niveau local dans mon potager j'évite de
labourer voilà je laboure pas j'essaie
de conserver les semis fin juillet semi
conserves les graines tout ça donc il ya
une idée de permanence et puis c'est
d'aménager des espaces différenciés dans
le potager donc vraiment ce qu'on a
enfin l'idée un peu de la permaculture
si vous souhaitez découvrir la
permaculture d'autres ateliers seront
organisés prochainement
sachez aussi qu'un jardin pédagogique
développé en permaculture existe à la
ferme de pulls loyer et qu'il est
possible de le visiter
eole est un prototype de voiture de
course sa particularité il fonctionne
grâce à l'énergie solaire
nous avons suivi ses premiers essais de
la saison sur le circuit de satory
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images une voiture de course à énergie
solaire
c'est sur le circuit de satory que
l'écurie automobile échos solar breizh
avait donné rendez-vous à ses
partenaires pour initier sa saison décès
2014 2015
l'occasion de présenter les dernières
améliorations apportées à eole un
prototype qui peut atteindre la vitesse
de 80 km heure en france en l'occurrence
ou d'un ensoleillement
une critique qui étaient sceptiques est
assez fixe en dire quelle que soit la
région
on peut rouler en totale autonomie donc
sans puiser d'énergie des batteries à 52
km heure quand on roule à 80 km/heure 80
90 km heure on consomme à peu près
autant qu'il bouilloire projet initié
dès février 2010 le prototype breton a
pu bénéficier de l'apport financier et
technique d'une quarantaine de
partenaires pour un coût total deux cent
cinquante mille euros
six mètres carrés de panneaux solaires
équipent le véhicule de quatre mètres
cinquante de long pour 188 kg de charge
sans le pilote
un pilote qui bénéficie d'une tablette
tactile en permanence dans le cockpit
pour connaître la consommation et
l'autonomie de son véhicule une
autonomie variant de 8
18 heures en fonction du soleil a une
incidence psychologique est assez
importante
c'est à dire que quand vous êtes dans
une voiture écrit vous avez le stress de
palais jusqu'au bout donc ça ça doit se
transformer par un meilleur niveau
d'information pour le pilote
on est complètement dans le véhicule du
futur lorsque le pilote se présentent
dans la voiture et se présente avec sa
tablette
donc on peut imaginer une voiture que
l'on ouvre avec la tablette avec un
programme personnalisé pour le pôle le
conducteur est ce que quand vous êtes
sur un véhicule électrique
c'est une conduite souple et c'est une
conduite intelligente avec pour point
d'orgue le world solar challenge en
australie dans un an
la team solar breizh continue sa
préparation lors de la course solaire de
savoie technolac les 7 et 8 juin
ils ont parcouru 204 km terminant
premier dans la catégorie
seul resterait c'est la fin de ce numéro
d' équilibre mais avant de se quitter en
jette un oeil à votre traditionnel
agenda environnementale le mercredi 25
juin l'atelier gac fois dans l'eau on
nous permettra de déterminer la qualité
d'un milieu aquatique
grâce à des prélèvements dans un bassin
d'eau douce jusqu'au 10 juillet une
exposition de photos noir et blanc vous
attend à la maison de l'environnement
pour découvrir des paysages avec pour
thème la douleur des arbres l'orée des
villes
voilà c'est tout pour ce mois ci nous on
se retrouve le 18 juillet prochain et
d'ici là n'oubliez pas la terre est
notre mère la respectons la salut